mais en fait l intelligence des
ordinateurs seront très très différent d
intelligence humaine dans leur
motivation
on peut construire leur motivation
puisqu'on va construire ces machines on
peut construire la motivation on peut
console en motivation en particulier
pour que leur motivation soit aligné
avec les valeurs humaines et non pas en
opposition avec les valeurs humaines et
on peut construire ces machines pour que
l n'ai pas d'ambition pour qu'elle n'est
pas le de l'instinct de survie pour
qu'elle n'ait pas envie de devenir
violente il ya soixante modèles c'est
pour que
ne se sentent pas déçu si on a envie d
étendre mais quand on met au point des
ordinateurs intelligents sont pas
programmées par l'évolution ils n'auront
pas un instinct de survie qui vont faire
qu'ils vont essayer de se défendre
contre nous ils vont faire ce que nous
on aurait décidé dans leur programmation
dans les objectifs qu'on aurait décidé
pour eux
je pense que
on voudra pas de donner à l'ordinateur
une tâche qui requiert de l'humanité
donc tout ce qui concerne les relations
entre les personnes de tout ce qui
concerne s'occuper d'eux des gens
malades et des enfants les personnes
âgées
moi j'ai pas envie que
mon coiffeur soit un ordinateur même si
peut-être qu'ils feraient mieux la job
donc mon massothérapeute soit un
ordinateur
donc c'est l'authenticité de la
communication humaine en fait qui est
irremplaçable dans l'automatisation
il n'y a pas intérêt à aller à un
concert de jazz si le six musiciens et
une est une machine parce que le jazz
c'est la communication de de l'émotion
en direct à travers l'improvisation
donc ce genre d'activités de
communication humaine va prendre plus de
valeur et c'est ce qui fait qu'on est
con et humains nécessaires
[Musique]